hey everyone so I'm pretty excited about
the next sequence of videos that I'm
doing there will be about linear algebra
which as a lot of you know is one of
those subjects that's required knowledge
for just about any technical discipline
but it's also I've noticed generally
poorly understood by students taking it
for the first time a student might go
through a class and learn how to compute
lots of things like matrix
multiplication or the determinant or
cross products which use the determinant
or eigenvalues but they might come out
without really understanding why matrix
multiplication is defined the way that
it is why the cross product has anything
to do with the determinants or what an
eigenvalue really represents oftentimes
students end up well practiced in the
numerical operations of matrices but are
only vaguely aware of the geometric
intuitions underlying it all but there's
a fundamental difference between
understanding linear algebra on a
numeric level and understanding it on a
geometric level each has its place but
roughly speaking the geometric
understanding is what lets you judge
what tools to use to solve specific
problems feel why they work and know how
to interpret the results and the numeric
understanding is what lets you actually
carry through the application of those
tools now if you learn linear algebra
without getting a solid foundation in
that geometric understanding the
problems can go unnoticed for a while
until you've gone deeper into whatever
field you happen to pursue whether
that's computer science engineering
statistics economics or even math itself
once you're in a class or a job for that
matter that assumes fluency with linear
algebra the way that your professors or
your co-workers apply that field could
seem like utter magic
they'll very quickly know what the right
tool to use is and what the answer
roughly looks like in a way that would
seem like computational wizardry if you
assume that they're actually crunching
all the numbers in their head here as an
analogy imagine that when you first
learned about the sine function in
trigonometry you were shown this
infinite polynomial this by the way is
how your calculator evaluates the sine
function for homework you might be asked
to practice computing approximations of
the sine function by plugging in various
numbers to the
and cutting it off at a reasonable point
and in fairness let's say you had a
vague idea that this was supposed to be
related to triangles but exactly how had
never really been clear and was just not
the focus of the course later on if you
took a physics course where sines and
cosines are thrown around left and right
and people are able to tell pretty
immediately how to apply them and
roughly what the sine of a certain value
will be it would be pretty intimidating
wouldn't it it would make it seem like
the only people who are cut out for
physics are those with computers for
brains and you would feel unduly slow or
dumb for taking so long on each problem
it's not that different with linear
algebra and luckily just as with
trigonometry there are a handful of
intuitions visual intuitions underlying
much of the subject and unlike the trig
example the connection between the
computation and these visual intuitions
is typically pretty straightforward and
when you digest these and really
understand the relationship between the
geometry and the numbers the details of
the subject as well as how it's used in
practice start to feel a lot more
reasonable in fairness most professors
do make an effort to convey that
geometric understanding the psionic
stream but I do think that a lot of
courses have students spending a
disproportionate amount of time on the
numerical side of things especially
given that in this day and age we almost
always get computers to handle that half
while in practice humans worry about the
conceptual half so this brings me to the
upcoming videos the goal is to create a
short int watchable series animating
those intuitions from the basics of
vectors up through the core topics that
make up the essence of linear algebra
I'll put out one video per day for the
next five days then after that put out a
new chapter every one to two weeks I
think it should go without saying that
you cannot learn a full subject with a
short series of videos and that's just
not the goal here but what you can do
especially with this subject is lay down
all the right intuitions so the learning
that you do moving forward is as
productive and fruitful as it can be I
also hope this can be a resource for
educators who are teaching courses that
assume fluency with linear algebra
giving them a place to direct students
that need a quick brush up I'll do what
I can to keep things well paced
throughout but it's hard to
simultaneously account for different
people's different backgrounds and
levels of comfort so I do encourage you
to readily pause and ponder if you feel
that it's necessary actually I'd give
that same advice for watching any math
video even if it doesn't feel too quick
since the thinking that you do on your
own time is where all the learning
really happens don't you think so but
that is an introduction I'll see you
next video
you